du bist in der 11 das heißt er denn noch
immer nicht du hast viele freunde und
geest manchmal abends aus
es ist eine schwierige sache mit denen
melodramen vielleicht gerade weil es
scheinbar so einfach ist
wir wissen ja genau wenn wir von etwas
gerührt sind
wenn wir aber uns dann fragen wovon
genau wir eigentlich gerührt worden sind
dann wird es schwierig wir möchten uns
ja nicht einfach zu gefühlen erpressen
lassen wollen wir wollen dort abgeholt
werden wo wir sind wo wir unsere welt
sehen wir wollen nicht hinterrücks
überrumpelt werden sie wissen was ich
ihnen sagen werde
vielleicht ist meine zeit einfach
gekommen ich weiß nicht ob ich mit dem
herz seines toten leben möchte
es ist ihre entscheidung aber ein herz
findet sich nicht so einfach eine höhere
servern aus frankreich die die
geschichte eine herztransplantation
erzählt eigentlich im kern ist die
lebenden reparieren ein krankenhaus
finden wir erfahren wer genau dieses
herz empfängt wir bekommen also zu der
einen geschichte der geschichte eines
tragischen unglücks auch die andere
geschichte die geschichte der heilungen
die geschichte der rettung
um
im vordergrund stehen die menschen die
in diese geschichte verwickelt sind und
deren schicksale sich mir verwegen weil
er diesen blick hat in dem jeder seinen
eigenen raum und sein eigenes licht hat
weil er diese größe hat eine geschichte
nicht auf ihren kern zu beschränken
sollen sie den fokus weit aufzuziehen
und ist eine große perspektive zu geben
deshalb ist die lebenden reparieren ein
sehr großer schöner und eindrucksvoller
film